it's a millionaire theme our we're
talking to real millionaires not
mythology not political wonk but real
ones people that have actually a million
dollars or more in investments and a net
worth Carol is with us in Houston Texas
hi Carol how are you I'm great how are
you better than I deserve
what is your net worth we have about
four million dollars excellent and what
is that in mostly mutual funds but about
three percent of it is in what I call my
emergency fund it's well over six months
of expenses that I just feel more
comfortable idea Banga having some cash
for if we want to take a nice vacation
or whatever like our good time you there
yep right here okay so most of it's in
mutual funds you got a nice fat cash
fund for fun and for emergencies and
then what else we all know how are we on
our home and we're on our vehicles
what's your house worth about three
hundred thousand okay cool very cool how
old are you guys I'm 54 my husband's 48
okay and how much of this did you four
million dollars did you inherit we
inherited none of it
you learn to be fair about $35,000 over
the years was gifted to us by parents or
grandparents and then as good stewards
of our money and good parents we gifted
forward we take forward to our kids so
both of my our oldest children who are
in their late 20s and my son is 30 we
helped we gave them about 25 thousand
between them to purchase their homes as
you don't get started in their in their
house good very cool so what has your in
your household income been range and
average though your working lifetime so
I started out making fifteen thousand
dollars a year with a college education
in the early 80s it was a was a tough
time and we went from you know from that
to at our highest level we were probably
making between my husband and me about
four hundred
$450,000 a year before I retired and I
retired at 49 and my husband's still
working okay and what were your careers
I was an information systems executive
serve as an accountant kind of worked my
way up and in my career as an
information systems executive for a
large hospital system and my husband is
a highly skilled software developer okay
all right very cool love it okay and
your degrees I'm guessing or in info
systems right now actually my degree was
in business management I'm a DBA in
management and my husband was a computer
science major okay all right and GPAs I
had a 3.8 and I believe this is around
3.4 okay cool and how much of the four
million is the result of you having
borrowed money to build wealth
absolutely none zero okay what part is
giving play in your financial plan I
think it's important to give we we
contribute to our church both on a
weekly basis and then they run building
funds and various fundraisers and then
in addition we are very interested in
the arts and so we contribute to the
arts as well as other charities that we
feel firmly about so except they're
important to us we we support yeah good
good cool what's the most expensive pair
of blue jeans you ever bought
thirty-five forty dollars maybe what's a
favorite vacation you've ever been on oh
gosh um we like to go to the wine
country so we go there for a week and no
stay it on a dollar night hotel and go
sip wine there you go a week okay so a
little nap our Sonoma action yeah
vanilla I got one okay very cool good
good what advice do you have for the 25
year old version of you that's listening
can this still be done in America I
think so I believe so my advice would be
be different from your millennial peers
I have two children that are Millennials
and one daughter who's about to go to
college and and so I would encourage
them to be different I have tried to
instill a
that's of saving in my kids I'm not sure
that the kids these days totally get it
unfortunately both my kids graduated
with no debt from college as well my
youngest our youngest will graduate with
no debt as well but I would say pay off
your mortgage as fast as you can mm-hmm
save save save if you're married and you
can live on one income so that you can
be in the situation where we were I
earned more than my husband did but when
it came time for us to like look at
changing our lifestyle which was
incredibly stressful we decided that I
would stop working we would live on his
income and we've been doing that
actually his income is actually dropped
by a third since then just because of
the economy but still live on his income
and I would say that we we go through
his paycheck every month but we don't
dip into savings and we don't feel the
need to so the four million came from
the four million came from just month
after month after month after month for
30 years saving money saving money
grinding it out a lots of investment
gains between 2008 and 2015 yeah and the
investment still well yeah and we stayed
we stayed invested when a lot of people
vote their money out no yes we rode the
roller coaster down which was heap
readily scary but we rode the roller
coaster back up mmm
yeah well the Warren Buffett said so I
asked him how much money he lost from
the stock market went down he said none
I didn't sell fuel you only lose if you
sell and that's exactly right but I
would I would encourage you know young
people today to not buy into the idea
that you have to go out to lunch every
day and spend $15 for a hamburger
thank you lunch my husband takes his
lunch to work he's worth four million
dollar how much smart yeah absolutely
absolutely pay cash for everything you
can no blue jeans for 35 bucks
understanding $100 night hotels yeah
there you go
love it love it your heroes Carol's in
order to talk to you thank you for
calling hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this
you know that really is a message
whether you've got 270 thousand dollars
in student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or five hundred thousand dollar
income